here's a cookie challenge that I don't
think you're gonna get it's time to see
if you can figure out which one of these
cookies is the actual crumble cookie and
which one is the Imposter let us know
which one you think is the dupe in the
comments in here is our spot on copycat
recipe for crumbles milk chocolate chip
cookie first you're gonna put the
ingredients I'm putting on the screen in
a bowl grab yourself a whisk and you
know what to do next we need a stand
mixer with the paddle attachment now
we're going in with two sticks of room
temperature unsalted butter next I put
in one and a fourth cup of light brown
sugar and a half a cup of granulated
sugar it's time to fluff a thigh now I
hold in my hands two room temperature
eggs that we are going to add in why
because they mix better with the batter
and they rise more easily we're gonna do
one and a half teaspoons of vanilla
extract remember our flour mixture after
you've mixed the vanilla for about 30
seconds we're gonna add this in slowly
here we go now it's time for the star of
the show two cups of milk chocolate
chips the dough is going to be gorgeous
like this and you're going to scoop the
cookies onto a baking sheet now good
things take time so we're gonna cover it
with plastic wrap put it in the fridge
and I'll be back tomorrow it is the next
day and I've got a sweet tooth now we're
just gonna bake them at 375 for about 18
minutes get a nice little close-up of
these oh